hoy en nuestra mesa de debate trataremos
el tema de las sociedades robotizadas lo
que esta cuarta revolución industrial va
a suponer para las personas en un futuro
inmediato para ello hemos invitado a dos
mujeres que en sus distintos campos de
trabajo conocen este mundo a la
perfección y nos darán una visión clara
de los pros y los contras de este asunto
que nos concierne y nos preocupa a todos
ellas son la doctora virus experta en
robótica e inteligencia artificial
buenas tardes doctora virus y ella la
señora limbo secretario de estado para y
más de massey representando el
ministerio de ciencia y tecnología
buenas tardes señora limbo buenas tardes
laura encantado de estar aquí muchas las
presentaciones entremos en materia
doctora virus está nuestra sociedad
actual
parada para asimilar los cambios
drásticos que los avances tecnológicos
implicarán en nuestra vida cotidiana
y
se puede repetir la pregunta al aura
[Música]
este senado a los periodistas por darles
a las preguntas más explícitas laura más
de aterrizar y sin rimbombancias que
estamos recién comidas mujeres se la
fórmula del nuevo doctor a virus está
nuestra sociedad actual preparada para
asimilar los cambios drásticos que los
avances tecnológicos se implicarán en
nuestra vida cotidiana
ay ay ay ay qué pues mujer hay más clara
donde puedo expresar y que yo he venido
a contestar de buena fe pero si va a
sacar punta todo lo que digo como que no
porque yo soy de ciencias no de letras
sin florituras lauda sin flor y seré más
concreta cree en ustedes por ejemplo y
hablando en términos de empleo que la
creciente robotización de nuestro tejido
industrial tendrá unos efectos
demoledores y se producirán muchísimos
despidos de los trabajadores en las
empresas
de mujer
y la preguntita enrevesada es para que
lo vamos a negar pero nada aquí estamos
para contestar y como responsable
directa de las políticas estatales de
nuevas tecnologías le diré que estamos
encima de este asunto que nos preocupa y
que haremos todo lo posible por mejorar
la situación actual disculpe señora
limbo pero no me ha contestado y ya sabe
que yo soy muy incisiva casi moral oiga
que usted me ha preguntado y yo le he
contestado lo que he querido pero le he
contestado o piensa que responder a una
pregunta sin decir nada claro no
requiere esfuerzo y preparación
por ejemplo el empleo de mi cuñado que
trabaja ensamblando coches en la force
me comentó que en su trabajo al igual
que en muchos otros sí han llegado
máquinas capaces de realizar su labor
con mayor precisión
es que les diría a esos trabajadores
anónimos para tranquilizarlos yo doña
laura si me permite una reflexión les
diría que lo tienen [ __ ] y perdón por
el palabro su cuñado ya que lo ha citado
o se subió al carro de la revolución
tecnológica se forma y cambia sin que se
haga charcuteros decidiremos bueno
aunque ya ni de charcutero va a poder
trabajar porque de aquí en nada hasta
los chorizos y las morcillas yo solo un
robot y tan rico o mejor aún una
impresora 3d que podrá elaborar pinchos
morunos con su palillo incorporado y
comestible
eso significa que mi cuñado se quedará
en la calle mujer en la calle en la
calle se podrá quedar en la sala de
descanso de la empresa tomando una
cerveza y unas bravas pero sin molestar
tocar las máquinas que esa tecnología
cuesta un riñón
todos son beneficios si ese trabajador
con la llegada de la robotización vivirá
cuerpo del reale incluso se reducirán
los accidentes laborales
bueno poniéndonos en lo peor lo mismo le
da una pequeña reacción al picante a
modo de urticaria si las bravas son
valientes pero por lo demás a vivir que
son tres días perfectamente y continúe
continúe con la entrevista no será mejor
porque no entiendo nadie está claro qué
pasará con el salario de estos
trabajadores de los que estábamos
hablando disminuirá
en base a que se les pagará habrá como
ya se especula una especie de salario
universal
desde el gobierno estamos analizando ese
y otros aspectos seriamente avanzando y
desglosando posibilidades porque nos
preocupa y creemos en un mundo más justo
he dicho no ha dicho nada otra vez está
está rehuyendo mis preguntas señora lynn
o soy capaz de repreguntar 500 veces se
lo advierto mujer no se lo tome tan a
pecho la verdad no tengo ni puñetera
idea de los efectos de la robotización
esa sobre los empleos bueno ni yo ni
nadie de mi gobierno para qué nos vamos
a engañar tiempo el tiempo seguro que
luego no es tanto eso con un par de
decretos sobre la marcha solucionado hay
que ver a usted con qué manía de
estresarse oye madre mía
anda que mi doctora virus hasta donde
podemos mejorarnos a través de la
tecnología a qué se refiere
a nosotros a la humanidad aún en que
mejoraremos y
y eso va a ser un no parar coches que
marchan solos auto conducidos casas
domóticas inteligentes dispositivos
electrónicos para tratar enfermedades
andrade apps por doquier
incluso para cambiar de marido
podremos hacerlo a través de la
eficiencia de la tecnología imagina
imagina un váter que analice sus
deposiciones al momento es o no es
apasionante doña la hora no lo es
hablan también de que gracias a esta
eclosión de una inteligencia artificial
capaz de optimizar se de manera
ilimitada si el transhumanismo cobrará
un papel preponderante en nuestra
sociedad
sra limbo si cómo ve usted la fuerza que
está adquiriendo esta corriente a nivel
cultural e intelectual
estás humanismo en mi opinión sobre el
transhumanismo
ah
hay que ver lo que hay hoy a estas horas
de la tarde a ella
pregúntese lo mejor al especialista a la
doctora ya mí a mí me da la risa
con la vista se le está tomando un té
pero más señora limón que no mujer que
no a ella pregúntele mejor a ella a niño
la del transhumanismo verdad cuando le
cuente al ministro lo que estoy
aprendiendo aquí está también doctor
andrús habrá que proteger la dignidad
humana frente a los robots y hay ya
alguna legislación sobre derecho civil y
la robótica a este respecto
muy buena la pregunta a la hora es muy
buena no cabe duda pues pues eso que es
muy interesante la felicito
pero vamos si se lo aseguro ahí pero es
que preguntas tan raras como la de la
trashumancia está claro en su humanismo
y demonios dice de trashumancia que
tiene que ver mover el ganado en
invierno lleva grano de un sitio a otro
a pasar con el transhumanismo está de
broma ya decía yo que me sonaba raro la
verdad oye que lo mismo con la escasez
de pastores de hoy en día encontramos un
filón económico
el robot pastor y es ese ni se cansa ni
sin sola ni siquiera necesita tener la
radio encendida a todas horas para matar
el aburrimiento
las mejores ideas surgen cuando menos te
lo esperas doctora los políticos la
practicamos mucho se nos ocurre algo
quizás a legislar a salto de mata nos va
de perlas diga que sí muy interesante su
propuesta doctora no cabe duda razón ya
muchos años de entrenamiento ahora el
señor al hígado tengo los axones y las
dendritas hiperdesarrollados establecen
conexiones a una velocidad de vértigo
yo axones de esos no tengo no me suena
leyendo interrumpir tan interesante
conversación pero el tiempo vuela y me
gustaría terminar la entrevista si son
tan amables de perdón perdón que es que
nos ponemos a hablar con este torrente
de sabiduría con este nivel de
profundidad de conocimiento y claro se
nos va en sant angelo es verdad es que
da gusto hablar sobre cosas a las
preguntas a las preguntas gracias y
céntrense que son lo que más quieran en
imagen
la siguiente cuestión no tiene aristas
ni es bien sencilla por ahí vas bien
mujer en las otras dos enciclopedias se
necesitaban para contestarle que opinan
de los cyborg como sabrán cada vez hay
más entre nosotros
los derechos de los cyborgs plantearán
nuevas cuestiones de cara al futuro esa
era la pregunta fácil
exoesqueletos brazos y piernas
motorizados interfaces cerebro-ordenador
para dar órdenes a la mente brazos viola
para para muchacha que quiere vas a
saturar el cerebro
no si lo de los brazos biónicos no es
mala moto todos saben de qué les hablo
señora pero no lo vamos a saber atrás
estamos de tratar de ello o no desde
luego y el gobierno está haciendo
esfuerzos ímprobos por mejorar todo ese
mundo de los de los jueces o de los
ciegos velamos por una sociedad mejor
apostamos por la tecnología y hemos
invertido animatrónica está progresando
para dotar a los androides de un aspecto
físico unas emociones y una gestualidad
cada vez más humano hoy en día vemos
robots con emociones sintéticas
llegaremos a verlos producir una cultura
propia
la propia pues no me extrañaría laura
porque como digan de ponerse de acuerdo
robots vivos androides y demás
artilugios tecnológicos yo yo no es por
ponerles mal cuerpo pero en unos años
nos vemos conviviendo con ellos en la
barra de un bar tomando cancha y las
tapas ya veremos lo que pasa que esos
seres son tercos tercos y como se les
meta en la cabeza que desaparezca el
pincho de tortilla lo llevamos de
colores vamos que me veo pidiendo una
ración de tuerca muy interesante esa
reflexión señalaron algo a tener en
cuenta
el bid en tinta que tendremos que
aprender a convivir también hablan de
que a nivel sexual se ha experimentado
una auténtica revolución en el campo de
la tecnología avances que nos dejan con
la boca abierta a diario así es que hay
mucho vicio en la sociedad a la hora que
que la gente está todo el día
con exceso en la cabeza y claro ya no
saben qué inventar
y los peores los japoneses que padecen
todo el día dormidos y las mata callando
que están llenando sus casas de ese ex
podcast y humanas hacer guarderías o
machistas mira es que lo pienso y me
pongo de mala leche a ver tú la emoción
sexual que despierta un robo c en la
cama se le mete en el lecho me alfonso
una se burguesas y se bloquean a 30 años
haciéndolo en la misma posición
cambiarle tu ahora el hábito yo soy más
de innovar pero es que no me siguen hija
mía y ahora que lo pienso de metió a mí
un cebo de esos apañado y bien de
atributos verdad como le sacó
rendimiento no si puede que la japonesa
no vayan mal encaminadas sigue habiendo
mucho machismo en este mundo de las
nuevas tecnologías y la robótica supongo
que habrán oído ustedes lo que pasó con
la consume
de las vegas' este año
ahora mismo lo caigo
al único sé que yo conozco es a mi
cuñado que es de córdoba pero es en
serio no han oído lo que pasó en ces la
feria de tecnología más importante de
eeuu
hoy no no conozco esa feria ni alta lo
sé cuenta le concedieron el primer
premio en la categoría de robótica sea
un juguete sexual femenino con con más
de 21 aplicaciones tecnológicas
su nombre es o sexy y fue creado por la
hora di carlo un startup en el tema pues
bien un mes después de premiar las le
han retirado el galardón por
considerarlo indecente e inmoral obsceno
y profano vaya me dejas de piedra vamos
que le premiaron a un vibrador sus
creadores lo llama masajeador llámalo x
y qué hace ese aparato que me llama la
curiosidad porque para que los hombres
se lo quiten del medio tiene que hacer
minería
es manos libres micro robótica avanzada
que imita la boca la lengua y los dedos
de una persona no vibra masaje incluso
estimula la zona con descargas de aire
y lo mejor de todo proporciona orgasmos
escritoria nash y vaginales combinados
ya que estimula ambas zonas con la misma
destreza que lo haría una pareja
experimentado madre mía como
como no lo van a descalifica
es el fin de los hombres si sólo le hace
falta cantar baladas mientras sus manos
una curiosidad que tengo yo muy claro
que no lo digo por mí es que tengo una
amiga vaya y yo también tengo otra
mirada
tenemos amigas necesitadas se cambiaría
que estar atentas al mercado menudo
regalo de reyes
bien señoras y señores en este tono
distendido terminamos esta entrevista
sobre las sociedades robotizadas
muchísimas gracias por estar aquí esta
tarde un placer doctora virus señora
lynn es fuerte el aplauso para ellas
[Aplausos]